Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlaff und ich begrüße euch zur 134. Ausgabe von UKW.
Und wenig überraschend machen wir weiter mit unserer Berichterstattung über
den Krieg in der Ukraine.
Das heißt, ich begrüße Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo.
Ja, letzte Sendung war vom, na, am 8.
Mai haben wir die veröffentlicht, am 7. glaube ich aufgenommen,
also ungefähr ein Monat ist vergangen.
Und ja, das war ein interessanter Monat, weil er erstmal so ein bisschen nur
versprach, dass wir more of the same haben,
darüber werden wir auch sprechen, aber dann war auf einmal alles anders und
es passierten wieder ganz wilde und aufregende Dinge und die wollen wir heute
natürlich mal in den Fokus nehmen,
aber erstmal wollte ich ein bisschen aufs Feedback eingehen und dann gucken
wir mal so die allgemeine Kriegslage an, quatschen dann ein wenig darüber,
was die Europäer versuchen mittlerweile politisch und auch militärisch anzustoßen,
was bei diesen sogenannten Friedensverhandlungen rausgekommen ist,
wie unser neuer Bundeskanzler sich in den USA geschlagen hat und dann natürlich die große Nachricht,
der sehr beeindruckende militärische Schlag der Ukraine,
die Drohnenattacke auf die nuklearen Airbases in Russland und später dann auch
nochmal der zweite Streich der Anschlag auf die Kerchbrücke.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, fangen wir einfach vorne an. Mit dem Feedback.
Du hast deine Reise beendet, also deine Reise in den USA ist jetzt sozusagen
abgeschlossen und wir hatten ja gesagt, wenn sich genug Leute melden,
dann machen wir da auch nochmal ein Special zu.
Es haben sich definitiv genug Leute gemeldet. Das kann man, glaube ich,
festhalten. Mit anderen Worten, wir werden das mal einleiten.
Das ist jetzt allerdings nicht diese Sendung, sondern heute wollen wir einfach
erstmal das normale Ukraine-Update liefern und werden dann irgendwann in den
nächsten Tagen sicherlich auch nochmal über die USA reden.
Genau. Dann gab es noch einen Kommentar von Philipp, Der schreibt,
zu den ausschließlich von Pinguinen bewohnten Inseln, wir erinnern uns hier
Trump und seine Zollankündigung,
die mit großem Pomp da im Garten des Weißen Hauses verkündet und auf so eine
Tafel geschrieben wurden, wo dann auch die Insel drauf war, die nur von Pinguinen bewohnt wird.
Und also dazu sagt Philipp, einige Banken scheinen die Adresse ihrer Kunden
nicht zu prüfen und akzeptieren diese von Menschen unbesiedelten Adressen als Wohnadressen.
Möglicherweise kann den Inseln der Geldwäschefilter der Banken umgangen werden,
weil sie auf keiner schwarzen Liste auftauchen. Schönes Detail.
Dann hatten wir...
Die Houthis, kurz erwähnt, ich weiß gerade jetzt gar nicht mehr in welchem Zusammenhang,
auf jeden Fall sagt Ralf dazu, eine Bitte sagt nicht, die Houthis,
das klingt für unbedarfte Zuhörer, als wäre es eine Minderheit.
Es handelt sich um eine Terrororganisation namens Ansar Allah,
die seit über 20 Jahren Bürgerkrieg im Jemen führt, Hunderttausende umgebracht
hat und in der Öffentlichkeit erst bekannt wurde, als sie im Roten Meer internationale
Handelsschiffe beschoss.
Vor ein paar Jahren haben die Saudis versucht, jedem bei der Bekämpfung zu helfen,
vermutlich tollpatschig und mit entsprechend vielen zivilen Opfern.
Das kam auch in den Medien vor. Houthi oder Houthi, also mit O oder U,
ist der Nachname einiger der Anführer. Da habe ich dann nochmal geguckt.
Wikipedia sagt dazu, die Houthi-Bewegung mit H-U geht in erster Linie von dem
religiösen und politischen Führer Hussein Badreddin al-Houthi aus.
Nach seinem Tod 2004 nahm die von ihm initiierte Bewegung Ansar Allah seinen Namen an.
Insofern würde ich mal sagen, danke für den Hinweis. Ich wusste nicht,
wo das herkommt, habe mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viele Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Andererseits sieht es aber so aus, als ob die selber quasi jetzt aus eigenen
Stücken sich unter diesem Namen versammelt haben und dann, würde ich sagen mal, ist es auch legitim,
sie so zu benennen.
Ja, aber trotzdem gut zu wissen, dass es sich nicht um irgendwie eine spezielle Volksgruppe handelt.
Ja, weil ganz ehrlich, das hatte ich auch so ein bisschen im Kopf,
aber ich bin da auch schuldig, ich habe mich mit dem Thema noch nicht so richtig beschäftigt.
Ist ja alles sehr komplex mit der Welt.
Jaro hat dann noch einen Hinweis zu den Motorradangriffen.
Nachdem die Ukraine die russischen Motorradangriffe verspottet hatte,
dazu vielleicht mal durch, ich glaube nicht, dass die Ukraine die Motorradangriffe
verspottet hat, aber es hat in den typisch pro-ukrainischen Medien durchaus
einen Raum eingenommen.
Wurde nun begonnen, die zunehmend erfolgreiche Taktik Russlands zu übernehmen
und zu kopieren, indem sie mit dem 425.
Skala-Regiment eine eigene Motorrad-Einheit ins Leben rief.
Hauptaufgabe der neu zu bildenden Einheit besteht im schnellen Durchbruch zu
den Stellungen der russischen Armee
in Angriffsaktionen und der sofortigen Änderung der Angriffsrichtung.
Dadurch können die Angriffstruppen diese schnell erreichen, was im Vergleich
zu normaler Infanterie mit größerem Gerät die Wahrscheinlichkeit verringert,
von Drohnen getroffen zu werden.
Naja, ja habe ich auch gehört, das wird auch tatsächlich sehr kritisch behandelt,
weil einerseits es gab zwar hier
und da an manchen Frontteilen so gegen Offensiven, kleine der Ukrainer,
im Wesentlichen ist es aber nicht im eigentlichen Sinne eine Offensive mit dem
Versuch einen Durchbruch in etablierte Stellungen zu erzielen,
wie das die Russen ja die ganze Zeit tun,
sondern das sind eigentlich immer eher so Momente, wo durch Beobachtung festgestellt
wird, dass irgendwelche Stellungen gerade schlecht besetzt sind.
Also, was weiß ich, Truppenrotation und dann kriegt man das mit und wenn irgendwo
Rotation ist, dann sind ja solche Stellungen immer sehr anfällig.
Kann gut sein, dass das an der Stelle so gedacht ist.
Vom Motorrädern hört man immer wieder viel, sieht aber nicht so viel.
Es gab auch schon, ich glaube schon vor zwei Jahren, wurden auch schon Elektromotorräder,
getestet. Ob die derzeit noch im Einsatz sind, das weiß ich nicht.
Die haben natürlich den Vorteil, dass sie auch noch leise sind.
Andererseits hat sich natürlich die ganze Frontlinie extrem geändert durch diese
permanente Drohnenüberwachung und die Bedingungen,
welche Taktik jetzt erfolgreich ist oder nicht, ändern sich laufend.
Es gibt immer wieder diesen Satz, das hört man in jeder Hinsicht,
dass nach drei Monaten ist eigentlich auf diesem Battlefield immer wieder alles anders.
Motorräder beim Militär sind ja nichts Neues, sondern die eingesetzte,
als es Motorräder gibt, auch militärisch.
Und klar hat man einen gewissen Mobilitätsvorteil, aber man ist halt auch in
hohem Maße verwundbar auf einem Motorrad.
Das ist halt grundsätzlich nicht so besonders stabil und natürlich auch im Gelände.
Also man muss da auch gut fahren können.
Da kann man nicht einfach irgendjemanden draufsetzen und dann gibt ihm.
Was jetzt so Drohnen angeht, habe ich jetzt neulich mal von einer Auswertung gehört,
wo jemand Videos von 1800 Drohnenangriffen ausgewertet hat und geguckt hat,
wie viele konnten denn entkommen und unter welchen Bedingungen.
Und die Wahl des Fahrzeugs scheint da nicht so entscheidend zu sein.
Also wenn man irgendwie von so einer Drohne angegriffen wird, meinten sie,
also egal ob zu Fuß oder im Auto oder mit dem Motorrad oder sonst wie,
die Drohnen kann man im Gelände einfach wohl nicht ausmanövrieren mit Geschwindigkeit oder sowas.
Man kann ihnen nicht durch Geschwindigkeit entkommen, was wohl,
sagen die Chancen, erhöht.
Es zum einen Rauch scheint zu helfen, also Nebelgranaten oder so, weil die dann, ja.
Es einem einfacher machen, weil der Drohnenpilot dann eher die Orientierung verliert.
Und ein anderes Ding ist halt durchs Gestrüpp.
So, da können die Drohnen natürlich auch nicht folgen. Also wenn es dann gelingt,
quasi irgendwie in dichten Bewuchs zu verschwinden, dann erhöht das auch deutlich
die Überlebenschancen.
Also ohne das, also im Schnitt waren es ungefähr 80 Prozent,
die nicht entkommen sind in diesen 1600 Videos,
sodass ja einfach in vier von fünf Fällen die Leute der Drohne nicht entkommen konnten.
Und so mit Rauch und Gestrüpp stiegen die Chancen irgendwie auf 50-50.
Also ist trotzdem, ja, ins Visier von der Drohne zu geraten, ist einfach nicht gut.
Ja, das wünscht man keinem.
Ja, also man ist jetzt auch viel berichtet worden, aber man macht sich glaube
ich gar keine Vorstellung.
Es ist einfach, die Drohne dominiert nicht nur diesen Krieg, sondern,
und das werden wir ja auch gleich nochmal in den anderen Betrachtungen,
in den anderen Vorfällen sehen, sondern ändert im Prinzip auch die gesamte militärische
Planung und Kriegsführung enorm und from the ground up.
Also das ist sicherlich die größte Revolution.
Revolution im Kriegsgeschehen seit langem und da muss man jetzt mal schauen,
was das alles noch mit sich bringt.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir nochmal einen kurzen Überblick über die
allgemeine Kriegslage. So, was ist eigentlich passiert?
Wir haben ja viel immer wieder berichten müssen, dass sich im Großen und Ganzen nicht viel tut.
Das stimmt eigentlich auch immer noch. Allerdings hat man jetzt schon gemerkt,
dass die Russen ihre Angriffe hochfahren bzw.
Weitere Truppenverstärkung vorgenommen haben.
Insbesondere nördlich von Sumi, das ist die Region, wo die Ukraine vor einem
halben Jahr in Kursk eingefallen ist und jetzt über fast ein halbes Jahr dieses
Gebiet auch gehalten hat,
bis dann der Plan nicht weiter aufging und sie sich zurückziehen mussten.
Und jetzt haben aber die Russen an der Stelle auch eine Gegenoffensive gestartet.
Die ist zwar nicht massiv, es wird so von 50.000 Soldaten berichtet,
die dort in dieser Gegend versammelt worden sind.
Das klingt jetzt erstmal viel, ist aber natürlich nicht genug,
um jetzt irgendwie diese Großstadt Sumi, die also eine Millionenstadt ist,
in irgendeiner Form einzunehmen.
Allerdings, und ich denke mal, das ist halt so die Strategie der Russen an der
Stelle, Man will halt die Ukraine an mehreren Fronten beschäftigen,
weil das eigentliche Ziel ist natürlich im Osten.
Also das eigentliche Ziel ist die gesamte Ukraine einzunehmen,
aber das ist natürlich nichts, was in irgendeiner absehbaren Zeit Russland möglich wäre,
aber sie sind einfach relentless und schicken einfach immer mehr Leute in den Tod.
Ja, und da muss man jetzt mal gucken, wie sich das entwickelt.
Es sind so ein paar kleinere Dörfer eingenommen worden jenseits der Grenze.
Ähnlich hat man das ja auch schon in Rakiv gesehen. Das kann durchaus sein,
dass sich Russland da auch festsetzt, aber es macht derzeit noch nicht so den
Eindruck, als ob es da zu irgendeinem größeren Durchbruch kommt.
Man kann nur hoffen, dass die Ukrainer an der Stelle gut vorbereitet sind,
diese Nordflanke dort auch zu sichern, weil wenn halt die Russen dann zu nah
an die Stadt rankommen, dann droht natürlich Artilleriebeschuss der Stadt etc.
Mit den entsprechend negativen Auswirkungen.
Dann gibt es im Osten auch nur sehr zähe Bewegungen, was so ein bisschen beunruhigend ist,
dass die Russen an so einem Brückenkopf über diesen Oskillfluss arbeiten in Luhansk.
Das kann derzeit noch eingehegt werden.
Im nördlichen Bereich von Luhans sind sie aber über diesen Fluss rüber.
Und das ist insofern bedrohlich, als wenn sich das zu sehr manifestiert,
dass es den Russen natürlich die Möglichkeit gäbe, dort wieder in das Gebiet
einzudringen, was sie ja schon mal besetzt haben, von dem sie ja zurückgedrängt wurden.
Und da ist zwar noch ein sehr langer Weg bis Charkiv, aber das ist ja sozusagen
da diese Region östlich von Charkiv und es bedroht auch die relativ wichtige Stadt Kupiansk.
Aber ganz so schlimm ist es noch nicht, auch wenn die Russen dort halt über
den Fluss rüber sind, heißt das erstmal noch nichts, aber das ist auf jeden
Fall so ein Bereich, der nicht so richtig glücklich stimmt.
Ja, ansonsten gibt es einfach enorm viel und da reden wir eigentlich viel zu wenig drüber,
weil es einerseits auch totally depressing ist und im eigentlichen Sinne auch
nicht kriegsentscheidend ist, aber die Beregnung der Ukraine durch Drohnen,
durch diese Schahed Drohnen,
durch ballistische Raketen und durch Cruise Missiles, das ist,
sagen wir mal, das eigentliche Problem.
Also gerade in den letzten Tagen kamen auch die großen Städte,
einschließlich Kiew, enorm unter Beschuss.
Permanent schlägt irgendwas ein, weil einfach nicht alles abgeschossen werden kann.
Die Luftabwehr wurde zwar wieder ein bisschen verstärkt, mittlerweile hat sogar
Israel bestätigt, dass sie ein Patriot-System jetzt auch abgegeben haben an die Ukraine.
Das hatten wir, glaube ich, hier kurz auch diskutiert.
Aber hier mal ein System, da mal ein System das hilft alles so,
aber Russland dreht da einfach das Rad auch gerade auf elf die feuern also im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes aus allen Rohren,
und das ist ein sehr großes Problem vor allem eben die ganzen Launches von bodengestützten
ballistischen Raketen aber eben auch die ganzen Cruise Missiles, die von Flugzeugen,
abgeregnet werden.
Ja, wobei...
Die Zahl jetzt der Cruise Missiles oder der ballistischen Waffen, also Raketen,
im Prinzip größeren Raketen, ist eher gering im Vergleich zu der Zahl der billigen, ja,
Schahit-ähnlichen Drohnen, von denen die so teilweise 500 Stück pro Nacht losschicken.
Und ja, da ist wohl der Plan der Russen auch, die Produktion so weit zu steigern,
dass sie jede Nacht 500 losschicken können und die kannst du natürlich nicht
mit Patriot bekämpfen oder es wäre halt,
ja, eine mehrere Millionen Dollar teuren Flugkörper Flugkörper gegen eine, weiß ich nicht, 20.000,
30.000 Dollar Drohne ist nicht ökonomisch, das hältst du nicht lange durch. Genau.
Aber da haben sie ja auch noch andere Methoden mittlerweile,
die Schallets, also sie werden sowohl mit F-16 und anderen Kampfflugzeugen bejagt,
es gibt Laserabwehrsysteme, die glaube ich jetzt schon in den Einsatz kommen
von den Briten oder zumindest getestet werden.
Und auch andere Anti-Drohnen-Drohnen sozusagen, also Drohnen,
die speziell darauf getrimmt sind, diese Drohnen abzufangen.
Das ist so ein permanenter technischer Wettlauf. Man muss sagen,
die meisten Scherhets holen sie auch vom Himmel.
Aber es bleiben halt einfach immer nochmal 100 übrig und irgendwie 100 Explosionen
irgendwo in Wohnhäusern und Kindergärten und Fabriken und so weiter,
das ist halt alles kein Spaß.
Und gut mittlerweile, also die Ukraine hat eine ganze Menge Gepard jetzt auch im Einsatz.
Die sind ohne jetzt groß Schlagzeilen zu machen, wurden halt mehr und mehr natürlich
refurbischt und geliefert seit Kriegsbeginn. und die,
funktionieren auch ganz gut gegen die Scheiddrohnen, das ist auch dann relativ
günstig, hatten wir ja schon mal das Thema, also 5 bis 10 Schuss oder so,
aber das ist halt nur im Umkreis dann von einigen Kilometern um,
den Panzer herum, die Reichweite ist halt nicht sehr hoch und Und sie haben
jetzt auch angefangen, quasi den Nachfolger vom Gepard,
beziehungsweise modernen Versionen der Luftabwehrkanonen, die mit demselben Kaliber arbeiten,
aber dann auf unterschiedlichsten Plattformen montiert werden können.
Auch auf Panzern, aber auch auf Schiffen und anderen.
Skyrager. Aber Skyranger, genau, so hieß das Ding genau.
Also ein paar Skyranger sind wohl jetzt auch im Einsatz, aber ich habe noch
nichts gehört, wie die sich jetzt dort bewährt haben.
Ja, das ist eine ziemlich beeindruckende Technologie. Da kann man sagen,
das scheint so ein Stück Militärgerät zu sein, was genau im richtigen Zeitpunkt
auf den Markt kommt, weil,
wie wir nachher auch noch diskutieren werden, es gibt erhöhten Bedarf an Drohnenabwehr,
insbesondere stationär.
Um einfach bestimmte Gebiete zu schützen, speziell Militäranlagen.
Und ja, dieser Skyranger, das ist also wirklich so ein Gepard plus plus.
Das ballert irgendwie in einer Irrengeschwindigkeit und Präzision um sich herum
und das ist vor allem auch dann eben ökonomisch auch darstellbar.
Wenn du also wirklich überschaubare Investitionen pro Schuss hast und nicht
so viele brauchst, um Drohnen abzuschießen,
das Teil ist in der Lage, ganze Schwärme zu neutralisieren, auch durch so entsprechende
Munitionen, die sich entsprechend sozusagen auf...
Die, glaube ich, programmierbar ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also das Gerät weiß quasi, wo das Objekt ist und die Munition kann dann...
In Echtzeit darauf programmiert werden, wann sie denn zersplittern soll.
Das heißt, irgendeine berechnete Distanz vor dem eigentlichen Objekt teilt sich
diese Munition auf und regnet dann natürlich in so einem kleinen Hagel irgendwie
auf diese Drohnen und dann ist natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass die Drohne das irgendwie überlebt, sehr gering.
Also das ist eine ganz andere Nummer als dieser Gepard, der im Prinzip normale
Munition verschießt und der mehr oder weniger genau treffen muss.
Ja, also es lässt sich zusammenfassen, die Russen greifen Wohnhäuser an und
die Ukraine greift Fabriken und Ölproduktionsstandorte und Militärproduktionsstandorte an.
Das ist alles nichts Neues und auch alles total deprimierend in gewisser Hinsicht,
aber so geht es halt hin und her.
Ja, wobei, also ganz, ich meine, natürlich greift Russland auch militärische
Ziele an mit den Drohnen.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie das nicht tun würden.
Sie hatten sogar einen Erfolg damit,
wo dann der ukrainische General zurückgetreten ist, weil Armee mit der Begründung,
dass er es nicht geschafft hat,
seinen Soldaten irgendwie dazu zu bringen, die nötigen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen.
Also entsprechend Obsek. Das heißt, da ist dann irgendwie...
Auch unter anderem ein Stützpunkt, eine zentrale Angebung, eine Ausbildungsstätte,
wo dann irgendwie Dutzend ukrainische Soldaten getötet wurden bei dem Angriff.
Also auch das kommt vor und wir kriegen natürlich wahrscheinlich auch weniger mit,
Und die Ukraine wird nicht von sich aus jetzt veröffentlichen,
wenn es nicht unbedingt sein muss,
wenn jetzt militärische Ziele getroffen worden sind aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen.
Die Russen machen das ja auch nicht.
Aber die Russen würden keine Sekunde zögern zu dokumentieren,
wenn die Ukrainer Wohnhäuser bombardieren würden.
Und das passiert halt dann doch sehr selten.
Das ist vorgekommen, aber das sind oft Fälle, wo einfach Drohnen,
die halt militärische Ziele angeflogen haben, auf dem Weg dahin abgeschossen
wurden und dann irgendwo halt in diesem Haus crashen.
Ja und bei russischen Angriffen kann man von vielen Angriffen definitiv sagen,
dass die gezielt auf quasi zivile Objekte...
Krankenhäuser, alles mögliche Lehrgärten, also das sind auch teilweise sehr
präzise Waffen, die da zum Einsatz kommen.
Also das sind schon bestimmte Cruise Missiles, die haben dann einfach KH 101
oder so, die hat glaube ich auch so eine Treffgenauigkeit von 10 Metern.
Wenn die jetzt in einem Krankenhaus landet, dann kann mir keiner erzählen,
dass das sozusagen ganz woanders hingehen sollte. Naja.
Letztes Beispiel jetzt auch in Kharkiv, das Rathaus im Prinzip,
wo sie auch ein Double-Tap mit ballistischen Raketen gemacht haben,
wo dann eben erst der Einschlag kommt, dann kommen die Helfer.
Und ja, dabei sind...
Das war glaube ich wirklich interaktiv. Ich dachte, du meinst jetzt dieses Verwaltungsgebäude
in Kherson, wo auch sehr offensichtlich ist, dass sie das direkt bombardiert haben.
Ja genau, Double Tap, das hatten wir auch schon mal, das ist halt so ein generelles
Problem, dass möglichst dann auch noch die Feuerwehr und die ganzen Retter auch
noch mit ins Leid gezogen werden.
Ja, ich meine, Ukraine macht auch teilweise Angriffswellen.
Insofern ist das nichts,
was die Ukraine nicht möglicherweise auch tun würde, aber die Ziele sind andere.
Da sind dann in der Regel irgendwelche Fabriken, die Kriegsgüter produzieren
oder Energie oder anderes.
Aber kein Double Tap, um jetzt Rettungskräfte zu erwischen, sondern Double Tap
im Sinne von ein paar Tage später geht man nochmal auf dasselbe Ziel los,
um auch noch die anderen Ölkanister auch noch zu erwischen.
Oder beziehungsweise man setzt erstmal so eine Fabrik in Brand und wenn sie dann gelöscht ist, dann,
Beschäftigt man auch weiterhin, um sozusagen auch Reparaturen entsprechend nach hinten raus zu zögern.
Naja, gut, aber schauen wir doch mal auf die Politik.
Es gab dann einen Vorstoß vor einigen Wochen, jetzt habe ich mir das Datum gerade,
es war kurz nach unserer Sendung war das tatsächlich, so am 9.
Oder 10. Mai, haben sich Macron, Merz, Tusk und Stama in Kief getroffen.
Also maximale Präsenz von Frankreich, Deutschland, Großbritannien und Polen,
also sagen wir mal den wichtigsten Militärmächten in Europa.
Und die haben halt große Einheit demonstriert und haben dann Putin gegenüber
nochmal so ein Ultimatum gestellt, ja am 12.05.
Dann muss aber jetzt hier mal bedingungsloser Waffenstillstand sein, or else.
Und man gab sich so, dass ja, man habe wohl mit Trump gesprochen und Sanktionen
wären jetzt in Vorbereitung und die würden dann eben in Kraft treten.
Naja, also Trump war natürlich am Ende wieder nicht hilfreich und hat sich da,
rausparlabert und hat nicht wirklich da.
Die Fronten geschlossen. Putin hat natürlich den Waffenstillstand abgelehnt,
sodass da sozusagen nichts bei rausgekommen ist.
Ich würde aber nicht sagen, dass jetzt diese Maßnahme sich ein Fehler war,
weil ich glaube, es ist relativ wichtig für die Europäer jetzt auch selber mal
Initiativen zu ergreifen und da auch die entsprechende Geschlossenheit zu,
demonstrieren, auch mal generell klar zu machen, wo man steht und auch zu sagen,
okay, wir finanzieren das jetzt auch, wir bauen auch unseren Militärapparat auf etc.
Und zwar auch unabhängig davon, was die USA sagen.
Sanktionen würden natürlich sehr viel mehr bringen, wenn die USA mit im Boot ist.
Es gibt derzeit auch schon eine von dem amerikanischen Senat zu 70-75% unterstützte
Sanktionsmaßnahmen, die auf dem Tisch liegt, die eigentlich nur noch abgestimmt werden muss,
die auch problemlos abgestimmt werden hätte können.
Sogar der Sprecher, der Johnson, der hat halt gesagt, so ja,
das können wir irgendwie machen.
Sprich, in der republikanischen Partei an sich ist die Unterstützung der Ukraine
eigentlich auch kein...
Aber kein Fragezeichen. Es gibt da genug Support. Der Einzige,
der das nicht unterstützt, ist halt Trump selber.
Und jetzt gibt es irgendwie noch Verhandlungen und jetzt sollen irgendwelche
Sanktionen noch ein bisschen abgemildert werden. Also man merkt einfach immer
wieder, wie Trump da seine Buddies in Moskau schützen möchte und das ist einfach
alles nur noch lächerlich und absurd.
Aber das ist nun mal so die Situation und die ganze Zeit hat er halt irgendwie
rausposaunt, ja man muss ja irgendwie Frieden schließen und er würde ja hier
den Krieg in 24 Stunden beenden. Es hat nicht ganz geklappt, würde ich sagen.
Und es ist alles natürlich vollkommen hanebüchen, was die Trump-Regierung derzeit macht.
Und er ist außenpolitisch auch so schwach. Also er bewirkt einfach gar nichts.
Das kann man mal sagen. Ganz im Gegenteil, er zögert eigentlich diesen Krieg
weiter raus durch sein Verhalten.
Und Europa muss schauen, wie sie mit dieser Situation umgehen,
weil man muss natürlich erstmal davon ausgehen, dass es auch die nächsten drei
Jahre noch so weitergeht mit ihm.
Und von daher denke ich mal, ist die USA politisch aus dem Rennen.
Ja, Trump hat so einen,
was heißt nicht Spitznamen, aber der Begriff Taco wurde halt geprägt von irgendwelchen
Wall Street Tradern als Akronym für Trump Always Chickens Out im Hinblick auf die Zölle.
Dass er erst Großzölle ankündigt und dann bevor die dann wirklich in Kraft treten
oder umgesetzt sind, dann wieder aussetzt und ja,
das scheint...
So auch bei den Friedensverhandlungen mit der Ukraine genauso zu sein.
Also wenn, ja, macht irgendwelche, stellt Forderungen, Deadlines und dann verstreicht
die Deadline und nichts passiert.
Und das ist halt wie wenn so, weiß ich nicht,
lediglich manche Mütter an der Supermarktkasse, wenn sie dann ihren Kindern
irgendwie fünfmal sagen,
lass das und wenn du das jetzt nicht sofort dann und wiederholen das irgendwie
zehnmal und nichts passiert und das Kind weiß das natürlich.
Und ja, also daran erinnert mich das ein bisschen.
Und mittlerweile ist das Problem, dass Trump nicht mehr richtig ernst genommen
wird oder das, was er sagt, nicht mehr ernst genommen wird.
Also wenn er was ankündigt, dann geht mittlerweile das Gros davon aus,
Das wird er sowieso nicht tun.
Was nicht immer der Fall sein muss,
aber das ist so, wie es jetzt aussieht, dass er weder von Putin ernst genommen wird,
noch glaube ich von einem Großteil der westlichen Regierungschefs und von China auch nicht.
Ja, eigentlich gar keiner, also wir wissen gar nicht, wer ihn überhaupt noch ernst nimmt.
Also ernst nimmt man ihn nur insofern, als dass er eben de facto an der Macht
ist und diese für seine Zwecke versucht zu missbrauchen, klar, aber,
Er hat selber kein politisches Verhandlungsgeschick, er versteht die ganze Situation
nicht, er hat keine Ahnung von Geschichte, er hat keine Ahnung von Diplomatie,
er hat keine Ahnung von Politik, er sieht halt alles irgendwie so aus mit seiner
Mafia-Brille und es geht ihm eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur darum,
selber da einen Reibach zu machen und alles andere ist ihm eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Und nach wie vor eine gute Erklärung,
er ist halt ein Reality-TV-Star und jede Woche ist sozusagen eine neue Show
und die Zuschauerzahlen von letzter Woche interessieren nicht,
es muss halt irgendwie neues Drama her. Ja, es muss halt.
Und ja, das erklärt halt eben auch eine ganze Menge von seinem Verhalten,
dass er natürlich immer versucht, irgendwie Mittelpunkt zu sein und gelernt hat,
dass das am besten funktioniert, wenn er irgendetwas Krasses von sich gibt.
Dann regen sich irgendwie wieder alle auf und er hat seine Schlagzeilen und
die neue Folge ist ein Erfolg.
Und das letzte Kapitel,
ich denke wir werden das heute nicht allzu viel darüber reden,
aber sein Fallout mit Musk und was das vielleicht für die Ukraine bedeutet, weiß man noch nicht.
Man weiß auch nicht, ob die beiden sich nicht wieder irgendwie vertragen, wohin das gehen wird.
Aber das war so ein bisschen jetzt die letzte Folge von.
Trump Reality TV und es wurde, glaube ich, dann auch mit Desperate Housewives
oder so verglichen, also was da passiert.
Man könnte fast glauben, dass es wirklich eine Inszenierung ist,
aber leider ist es auch Realität, was da passiert. Das ist leider nicht nur Show.
So sieht es aus. Ja, kommen wir mal zu diesen eigentlichen Friedensverhandlungen,
die ja dann tatsächlich stattgefunden haben.
Also kind of. Es gab die Einigung, dass man sich in Istanbul trifft.
Und es ist generell, ich würde sagen, nicht überraschend, dass ausgerechnet
die Türkei und Erdogan an dieser Stelle ein Ort sein können,
wo die sich überhaupt treffen.
Also nicht nur, weil es jetzt geografisch nahe ist, sondern weil vor allem natürlich
Erdogan es ja immer geschafft hat,
ganz geschickt da die Balance in seinem Verhältnis zum Westen und zu Russland
zu warnen, obwohl die Türkei halt NATO-Mitglied ist und so weiter.
Also das ist ja auch alles sehr absurd. Aber er ist halt auch selber so ein
Strongman, den Putin glaube ich noch so halbwegs ernst nimmt.
Allein schon, weil er irgendwie, wenn die Russen mal über seine Grenze rüberfliegen,
die russischen Flieger auch sofort abschießen.
Das hat ja die NATO bisher noch nicht geschafft.
Also die anderen NATO-Staaten haben es noch nicht geschafft.
Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass das eine NATO-Operation war,
sondern das war halt einfach so, wie die Türkei das gerne handhabt.
Und so war es beeindruckend halt Putin. Naja, auf jeden Fall,
dort sollten diese Treffen stattfinden.
Haben sie dann auch und das ist ja dann auch mit einem entsprechenden diplomatischen
Getöse verbunden gewesen.
Aus der Position der Ukraine heraus. Ich meine.
Wie Selenskyj das schafft...
Dieses Verhältnis zu der USA irgendwie aufrechtzuerhalten, verdient eigentlich schon einen Oscar.
Also das ist was für Demütigungen das Land hat einstecken müssen und auch er
persönlich, aber trotzdem lassen sie sich davon eben nicht abhalten.
Er ist eigentlich wieder totaler Anti-Trump und schafft es aber dadurch auch
in irgendeiner Form immer alle Optionen offen zu lassen.
Jetzt gab es Trumps offensichtlich sinnlose Forderung nach einem Waffenstillstand,
den die Ukraine ja nie wollte, ist aber dann trotzdem darauf eingegangen,
hat den auch teilweise durchgezogen, einseitig, im Wesentlichen um zu zeigen,
dass die Russen das nämlich genau nicht tun.
Also er möchte einfach die Ukraine dort aus der Argumentation herausführen,
dass ja irgendwie die Ukraine nichts für einen Frieden tun würde.
Auch wenn sie genau wissen, dass eigentlich Russland an Frieden überhaupt gar
kein Interesse hat und an Friedensverhandlungen auch nicht und ein Waffenstillstand
auch überhaupt nicht im Bereich des Realistischen ist. Das hat sich ja gezeigt.
Ja, sie haben also zwei Tage mal offiziell einen ausgerufen,
als sie ihre Militärparade gehabt haben, aber de facto gingen die Kämpfe da
auch weiter. Das ist also alles nur Gewäsch.
Was die Ukraine wohl gemacht hat, ist, dass sie eine Zeit lang davon abgesehen
hat, Ölinfrastruktur anzugreifen.
Wobei das jetzt nicht ganz sicher ist, ob das jetzt wirklich ein Entgegenkommen
war oder halt einfach nur ein Signal und man sowieso erstmal auf andere Ziele umschiften wollte.
Aber das scheint wohl tatsächlich stattgefunden zu haben von Seiten der Ukraine.
Das meinte ich damit auch. Sie sind dem teilweise entgegengekommen.
Das war halt genau diese Phase, wo sie den USA zugesagt haben,
dass sie jetzt, weil die USA so, ja, nee, ihr müsst aber hier mal die Angriffe
auf die ölproduzierenden Standorte einschränken.
Und das haben sie dann auch getan. Sie haben dann andere Ziele angegriffen.
Aber sie sind dieser ominösen Forderung der Amerikaner halt einfach nachgekommen,
um sagen zu können, hier guck mal, wir haben doch alles gemacht, was ihr wolltet.
Auch wenn wir nicht glauben, dass es irgendwas bringt, aber wir haben es einfach mal trotzdem gemacht.
Das heißt nicht, dass wir jetzt nicht andere Ziele angegriffen haben,
aber diese eine Forderung, der sind wir einfach mal gefolgt für 30 Tage.
Danach ging es aber auch wieder weiter.
Und das ist das, was ich meine, das ist sozusagen die Verhandlung.
Es geht immer darum, eine Position zu schaffen, wo man dann nicht mehr argumentieren
kann, aber die Ukraine hat ja nicht, sondern wo man sagen kann,
okay, was hat Russland jetzt gemacht? Antwort, gar nichts.
Und das war dann eben auch die Situation, als diese Friedensverhandlung in Istanbul,
die erste Runde da gestartet wurde, dass,
Russland dann zwar da aufgelaufen ist, aber die haben halt nur so die dritte Garde hingeschickt.
Also da war noch nicht mal der Lavrov, noch nicht mal der Außenminister war
da, sondern das waren so irgendwelche Leute, die eigentlich überhaupt nichts
zu entscheiden haben, während halt die Ukraine dort nicht nur mit der ersten
Verhandlungsgarde angeritten ist, sondern Zelensky selber war dann halt auch bei Erdogan.
Er war dann in Ankara und hat gesagt, naja, wenn jetzt hier Putin kommt,
dann treffe ich ihn gerne in Istanbul.
Er kam dann nicht, dann ist er halt auch nicht mehr nach Istanbul gereist,
hat aber trotzdem die Gelegenheit zum Staatsbesuch bei Erdogan genutzt.
Und später gab es dann halt noch den zweiten Termin, wo dann sozusagen nochmal
verhandelt wurde und Spoiler-Alert also in beiden Fällen kam natürlich kein
Friedensverhandlung bei raus und auch kein Waffenstillstand sondern es wurde
nur ein Gefangenenaustausch jeweils,
vereinbart, das ist auch okay aber das findet halt sowieso immer statt,
nur dass dann eben die Vorzeichen dann etwas anders waren.
Ja, aber es war eine größere Zahl, also irgendwie glaube ich jeweils 1000,
Gefangene ausgetauscht.
Also wurde es ein bisschen vereinbart. Das sind glaube ich noch nicht alle tatsächlich.
Aber es gab jetzt wieder Leute, die entlassen wurden aus teilweise dreijähriger
Gefangenschaft und so weiter. Genau.
Und das Spannende an dem zweiten Treffen war,
dass Russland wohl geplant hatte,
so als Vorbereitung für dieses zweite Treffen einen massiven Luftschlag in der
Nacht vorher durchzuführen gegen die Ukraine.
Und der kam dann nicht,
weil eben die Ukraine sich auch was
überlegt hatte im Hinblick auf die Verhandlungen und dann die Operation.
Spinnennetz dann gestartet hatte und ja, die Russen dann mit runtergelassenen
Hosen irgendwie dann am nächsten Tag dastanden.
Es war auch interessant, in die Gesichter zu gucken von der russischen Delegation
bei dem zweiten Treffen.
Die sahen alle not amused aus. Die haben halt alle saure Gesichter gemacht,
weil die sich das halt anders vorgestellt hatten.
Und da hat die Ukraine, also Russland,
sehr erfolgreich dazwischen gefunkt und vermutlich tatsächlich unter anderem
auch Flugzeuge erwischt,
die betankt und aufmunitioniert waren und eigentlich in der Nacht, ja,
die Ukraine angreifen sollten und dazu kam es dann nicht mehr.
Erzählen wir doch mal, was eigentlich passiert ist. Also es gab diese Angriffe.
Angegriffen wurden insgesamt fünf Airbases quer verteilt über Russland.
Eine in Momansk, also sehr weit oben im Norden in der Nähe der Polarregion,
da wo die Russen ihre strategische U-Boot-Flotte auch haben,
aber eben auch eine große Airbase.
Zwei in der Nähe von Moskau, einer weiter im Osten und einer sehr weit im Osten.
Eine so in der Höhe von Kasachstan, eine andere hinten schon bei China.
Und warum wurden diese fünf Airbases angegriffen?
Das waren die Standorte, wo die großen strategischen Bomber der Russen geparkt
sind. Und strategische Bomber sind halt große Bomberflugzeuge,
die eine extreme Reichweite haben.
Die sind nicht besonders schnell, aber die können sehr viele Waffen tragen und
können die eben aus großer Distanz in die Nähe bringen, in so einen Abschussbereich,
wo dann eben die Raketen und Cruise Missiles dann von alleine weiter fliegen.
Das sind im Wesentlichen die TU-95, das ist so ein 50er Jahre Flugzeug,
So ein riesiger Turboprop-Bomber, dann die TU-160,
das ist so eine etwas modernere Variante aus den 60ern und die TU-22M.
Und das waren die Ziele, die die Ukraine jetzt erledigen wollte,
weil das sind auch die Flugzeuge, die derzeit einfach für am meisten Ärger sorgen.
Da kommen die Großmissiles her, die also so riesige Bombenlast abwerfen über
der Ukraine und die für einen Großteil der wirklich schwerwiegenden Angriffe
der letzten Monate verantwortlich sind.
Und ja, wie macht man das jetzt?
Man macht das natürlich mit Drohnen und was sich die Ukrainer haben einfallen
lassen ist eine wirklich gewiefte Operation.
Sie haben also spezielle Angriffsdrohnen mit so je zwei Stangenbomben gebaut, also Quadrokopter,
haben die dann nach Russland geschmuggelt in die Stadt Tscheljabinsk und dort
haben sie so eine Lagerhalle angemietet.
Und in dieser Lagerhalle haben sie dann so Container zusammengebaut aus Holz,
die so aussehen, als würde es sich dabei um so Tiny Houses handeln.
Also so in Containerform mit Türen und Fenstern und davon haben sie dann offensichtlich
so zehn Stück produziert und das Besondere daran war,
dass die oben einen doppelten Boden oder vielmehr ein doppeltes Dach hatten.
Das heißt, man hat das diesen Häusern so nicht angesehen.
Die waren innen halt im Wesentlichen leer, aber oben war quasi so eine doppelte
Decke und diese doppelte Decke, dort wurden dann eben diese Drohnen platziert.
Und das müssten so an die 25 Drohnen pro Container gewesen sein,
zwei Container pro Flughafen.
Also auf einem Truck wurden die dann später zu diesen Flughäfen von normalen
russischen Spediteuren, die keine Ahnung hatten, dorthin gefahren.
Das heißt, die haben das halt einfach gesagt, ja, wir haben hier so ein Tiny
House, das muss da irgendwo in die Gegend, komm mal her mit deinem Truck,
wir laden die mal da drauf.
Und dann sind sozusagen der Truck mit diesen zwei Containern hinten drauf losgeschickt
worden und wurde dann immer wieder so telefonisch irgendwo hingeleitet.
Ja, fahr mal da hin, fahr mal da hin.
Das heißt, die haben den auch so Schritt für Schritt begleitet und immer gesagt,
wo er irgendwie hinfahren soll.
Und ja, das ging dann aber sozusagen in alle Richtungen, eben quer über Russland
verteilt an all diese ganzen Standorte.
Und das Ziel war, diese Container in der Nähe dieser Airbases abzustellen.
Also nicht wirklich komplett abzuladen, sondern mit dem Truck quasi zum Stehen
zu kommen und dort sollten dann diese Fahrer auf jemanden warten,
der ihnen die Dinger dann irgendwie abnimmt.
Das war sozusagen der Trick, mit dem sie dazu gebracht haben,
einfach irgendwo auf so einem Parkplatz in der Nähe dieser Flughäfen stehen zu bleiben.
Naja, was die Truck-Treiber halt nicht wussten ist,
dass da diese Drohnen drin sind und schon gar nicht was dann als nächstes passieren
würde, weil es sieht eben so aus, als ob diese Tiny Houses und mit diesen Drohnen,
die waren halt sehr gut ausgerüstet.
Das heißt, dort waren also erstmal noch zusätzliche Akkus mit verbaut,
um diese Drohnen also auch über einen längeren Zeitraum, ich weiß jetzt nicht
genau, wie lange die unterwegs waren, aber bei den Distanzen,
das dürfte schon eine Weile gedauert haben, also mindestens eine Woche,
denke ich mal, mindestens in zwei der Fälle.
Dass die halt also auch weiterhin alle geladen sind, sprich da ist also richtig
viel Akkukapazität wahrscheinlich mitgegeben worden,
damit diese Drohnen einfach bis zum Schluss auch voll in Power sind und natürlich
haben die auch die ganze Zeit kommuniziert und wie sie kommuniziert haben, wurde dann später klar,
die waren halt einfach mit SIM-Karten im russischen Mobilfunk eingebucht.
Nicht alle drohen unter Umständen, sondern vielleicht auch jetzt nur erstmal das System an sich.
Aber die Ukrainer waren in der Lage, den Ort rauszufinden und die Kommunikation
aufrecht zu erhalten mit diesen Trucks und haben es geschafft,
diese Trucks alle mehr oder weniger zeitgleich an diesen finalen Orten ankommen
zu lassen. Also das war sozusagen auch ein Ziel.
Es wurde nicht eins nach dem anderen angesteuert, sondern sie haben es auch
so losgeschickt und so in Schritten weitertransportieren lassen,
dass eben diese Trucks alle mehr oder weniger zur selben Uhrzeit an diesen Airbases ankamen.
Und dann wurden diese Trucks von außen aktiviert, sodass nämlich oben das Dach
mit so einer Motorkonstruktion seitlich weggefahren wurde und einfach runterfiel.
Also es ist einfach so, oben hat sich sozusagen das Dach weggeschält und es
ist auf den Boden gefallen.
Womit eben dann der komplette Container vollständig in der Luft stand oben,
dieser doppelte Boden, sprich die Drohnen konnten von dort direkt gestartet werden.
Und jede Drohne hat sich dann, das weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau,
ob jede Drohne selber mit SIM-Karten ausgestattet war oder ob der Truck selber
dann als Hub fungiert hat.
Weiß nicht, ob du da was zu gelesen hast.
Also einer von diesen beiden Ansätzen wird es gewesen sein.
Auf jeden Fall waren dann entsprechende Operator in der Lage und es gab für
jede Drohne einen eigenen Operator.
Sprich, da wird also irgendwo in der Ukraine in irgendeinem Keller,
wenn da irgendwie 150 Leute, 150 Drohnen Operator gesessen haben,
jeder seine eigene Drohne gesteuert, die halt dann als FPV-Drohne losgeflogen ist.
Es gibt so ein recht beeindruckendes Video von der einen Airbase,
ich glaube in Belaya war das, wo also der komplette Flug im Video festgehalten ist.
Ich habe das dann mal auf Google Earth nachgemessen.
Die Drohne hat sechs Kilometer zurückgelegt, also stand auf dem Parkplatz sechs
Kilometer entfernt und ist dann auf direkten Wege zu dieser Luftbasis geflogen.
Hat dann eine Minute damit verbracht, kurz die Lage zu checken,
sich die anderen, die Flugzeuge anzuschauen, die da sind, hat sich dann einer
ausgesucht und hat dann in Seelenruhe genau die Stelle angeflogen,
wo die Drohne dann explodieren sollte und das Ergebnis war einfach,
dass einfach ein Shitload an Flugzeugen.
Beschädigt wurde und teilweise komplett zerstört wurde.
Eine unglaubliche Aktion. Die Ukraine hat gesagt, sie hätten 41 Flugzeuge zerstört
oder beschädigt oder angegriffen.
Sprachen außerdem davor, dass es sich dabei um 34 Prozent der strategischen
Luftwaffe Russlands gehandelt habe, was sie dort angegriffen haben.
Wobei diese Aussage sich bisher noch nicht so vollständig bestätigt hat und
auch nicht vollkommen klar ist, wie es gemeint war.
Also es kann auch sein, dass sie 34 Prozent der Flugzeuge, die sie angetroffen
haben, angegriffen haben und ob das dann auch alles erfolgreich war,
ist nochmal eine andere Sache.
Es gab jetzt diverse Auswertungen von Satellitenbildern, von diesen Videos,
wo also akribisch gezählt wurde, was denn nun tatsächlich alles in Flammen aufgegangen
ist und was definitiv zerstört war.
Ich glaube so der aktuelle Tally von was wirklich visuell bestätigt werden kann,
war so 22 bis 25 Flugzeuge in der Größenordnung, davon 12 auf jeden Fall mit
großer, also mit hundertprozentiger Sicherheit komplett zerstört.
Also da ist alles nur noch explodiert und Rauch aufgegangen.
Weil wie du schon gesagt hast, diese Flugzeuge waren ja kurz vor ihrem Einsatz.
Mit anderen Worten, die waren alle aufgetankt, das brennt gut.
Und sie hatten vor allem auch noch selber die ganzen Cruise Missiles schon unter dem Flügel montiert.
Das hat man auf den Videos auch gesehen, die dann sicherlich teilweise auch mit explodiert sind.
Also es ist unter anderem auch noch Tanklager angegriffen worden.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich auch eine große Zahl an Crews Missiles in dem Zuge
auch noch zerstört worden.
Ja, also es werden wohl mindestens um die 20 Flugzeuge gewesen sein,
das kann man glaube ich definitiv sagen und potenziell mehr.
Eine Sache, die halt auffällig ist, ist, dass keine einzige TU-160,
also der ganz moderne Bomber,
zerstört oder angegriffen wurde, obwohl jede Menge davon auf dem Flugfeld da waren. Ja.
Und das ist insofern von Interesse, dass es auch möglicherweise,
also warum dem so ist, ist unklar.
Kann sein, dass das vielleicht Decoys waren, sah aber nicht so aus.
Also keine echten Flugzeuge, sondern irgendwie Attrappen, weiß man nicht.
Oder dass die Ukraine halt absichtlich diesen Teil von Russlands nuklearer Triade verschont hat.
Und mit sozusagen auch der Message, wir hätten die auch zerstören können.
Das heißt, dass sie sozusagen quasi auf der einen Seite einen massiven Schlag
den Russen zugefügt haben und gleichzeitig aber,
ja, wir hätten auch mehr gekonnt.
Ich kenne diese These, ich würde dem mal ein Argument entgegenhalten,
weil es ist so, die Angriffe, die auf die Ukraine durchgeführt wurden,
wurden zu nahezu 100% von diesen anderen beiden Typen gemacht.
Das heißt, die TU 160 wäre zwar ein Ziel gewesen, aber das sind nicht die Flugzeuge,
mit denen tatsächlich die Angriffe auf die Ukraine geflogen werden.
Und der Grund ist schlicht der, dass die TU 160 im Betrieb für die Russen viel
teurer ist als die TU 95. Und deswegen kamen diese anderen zum Einsatz.
Mit anderen Worten, die haben jetzt erstmal die Flugzeuge bevorzugt zerstört,
von denen sie sicher wussten, dass die an den aktuellen Angriffen beteiligt
sind. Und jede Drohne kann ja nur ein Flugzeug zerstören.
Das heißt, dann ist halt auch klar, worauf man geht.
Das heißt ja auch nicht, dass es nicht noch eine Nachfolgeoperation gibt und
so weiter oder sie da nicht schon noch irgendwie eine weitere Sache geplant haben.
Aber von den 150 Drohnen, die sie in diesen Dingern hatten, meinten sie,
hatten sie 115 zum Einsatz gebracht, die also wirklich losgeflogen sind.
Das hat übrigens damit zu tun, dass ein Truck ist offensichtlich der in Ukrainka,
der ist offensichtlich vorher geflogen.
Explodiert oder wurde nicht richtig ausgelöst, es ist noch ein bisschen unklar,
was da schief gegangen ist.
Das heißt, es hat eigentlich nur die anderen Flugplätze Olenya, Ivanovo,
Diageli, Levo und Belaya getroffen und dort haben dann die Flugzeuge eben das
ausgewählt, was sie ausgewählt haben.
Also aufgrund aber, was ich jetzt auch gehört habe, als neuestes Update,
aufgrund Und eben weil die Ukraine so viel halt vor allem ja,
weil die TU-95 zerstört hat und TU-22,
dass jetzt Russland angefangen hat, eben TU-160 zu nutzen.
Also gezwungen ist, die jetzt zum Einsatz zu bringen und ja,
entsprechend abzunutzen.
Also auf jeden Fall fand ich es bemerkenswert, auch wenn nicht wirklich klar ist, warum.
So wurden an mehreren Standorten, man kann das dann auch sehen,
wenn man sich die Videos anguckt, wie da scheinbar ein Haufen TU 160 in der
Reihe steht, aber die im Prinzip alle ignoriert werden.
Und das und es scheint mir auf jeden Fall Absicht zu sein, dass sie das so gemacht haben. Warum das,
Und das können wir nicht hundertprozentig sagen,
aber bei 150 Drohnen, dass dabei nicht eine einzige angegriffen wurde und zerstört wurde,
erscheint mir kein Zufall zu sein.
Also ich weiß nicht, wo du das hernimmst, dass keine 160 getroffen wurde.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das so ist.
Ja, also sicher, aber es ist nicht eine einzige confirmed. Also in den Bildern so.
Ja gut, aber es ist halt auch nur die Hälfte von dem confirmed,
was die Ukraine behauptet.
Und die sind auch relativ klar dabei. Also es kann durchaus sein,
dass eine 160er auch noch mit getroffen wurde, aber die war halt nicht im Fokus.
Und letztlich, sie konnten ja nicht alle zerstören, also mussten sie priorisieren.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist auf jeden Fall noch eine erwähnenswerte Anomalie an der ganzen Sache.
Aber eins wollte ich noch loswerden und sagen,
die Aufgabe, Drohnen in einen Truck zu packen, mit Sprengstoffen,
jede der Drohne hat irgendwie Sprengstoffe, muss mit Strom versorgt werden,
wie du richtig schon erwähnt hattest.
Und muss halt aber alles so gesichert sein,
dass es so einem Transport mit einem russischen Fahrer und auf russischen Straßen standhält.
Und du hast da Schlaglöcher,
wilde Kurven und Fahrmanöver und Beschleunigung und da darf halt sich nicht
eine Granate irgendwie lösen oder die sich verschieben auf der Plattform.
Das heißt, das Ganze muss eben ziemlich solide sein.
Bombensicher sozusagen, ja.
Ja, auf der einen Seite extrem sicher, dass es nicht während der Fahrt alles
um die Ohren fliegt, was wahrscheinlich bei einem Truck möglicherweise auch passiert ist.
Und muss aber dann entsichert werden alles.
Das heißt, du musst dann irgendwie die Stromverbindung trennen.
Du musst eventuelle Sicherungen finanzieren,
Und entsichern, also brauchst auf jeden Fall welche und muss dann relativ robuste
Verankerungen auch noch lösen.
Also ich will sagen, das ist nicht so einfach, wenn du wirklich durchdenkst,
was da alles schief gehen kann,
das so hinzukriegen, dass ein uneingeweihter Fahrer du da hinschicken kannst
und du alles vollautomatisiert dann öffnen kannst.
Also das Ganze ist schon fast ein Hollywood-Plot.
Es gibt ja auch eine Reihe von Romanen, in denen gemutmaßt wurde oder solche
Drohnenplattformen, die dann hunderte oder tausende von Drohnen ausspucken.
Beschrieben sind. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass solche Wartime Science Fiction
in Ukraine eine sehr begehrte Lektüre sein dürfte.
Und ja, du hast recht, also das war hochkomplex. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu
den Targets, um das noch abzuschließen.
Also neben den drei Bomberntypen gab es auch noch zwei konfirmte Angriffe auf A-50 Flugzeuge.
Und die A50, die hatten wir schon mal erwähnt, das ist auch ein wichtiges strategisches
Element der russischen Luftwaffe.
Das sind quasi diese AVEX-Flugzeuge der Russen, also die Aufklärer.
Das sind also die großen Transportmaschinen, die oben ein Radar haben.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es Transportmaschinen sind im eigentlichen Sinne,
aber den Flugzeugtyp, den weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht genau.
Also worauf der basiert, weiß ich nicht genau. Die A-50 ist halt das,
wo sie oben Radar drin haben und drin sitzt halt die Crew.
Und ich glaube, wir hatten diese A-50, da gab es einen Abschuss der Ukraine.
In Krasnodar, da im,
Süden, dann gab es, ist nicht sogar auch bei dem Putsch eine abgeschossen worden von dem Prigoshin?
Ne, das war was anderes, das war keine A5, das war so eine fliegende Kommandozentrale,
die abgeschossen wurde, aber nicht mit Radar.
Russland hat von denen insgesamt nur 10 gehabt.
Es ist völlig unklar, wie viele davon überhaupt funktionieren und je nach Korrespondent,
die man so hört, war irgendwas von 2 funktionieren noch bis 4 bis 5 funktionieren noch.
Aber 5 ist auch die höchste Zahl, die ich gehört habe. Nichts genaues weiß man nicht.
Jetzt sind bei diesem Angriff 2 angegriffen worden und angegriffen heißt,
es gibt ein Video, wie die Drohne direkt auf dem Radar landet und danach ist
das Bild weg mit anderen Worten.
Da dürfte von diesem Radar nicht mehr viel übrig geblieben sein und wahrscheinlich
auch von dem Flugzeug nicht so sehr viel,
und wenn das also es war nur so bei dem einen Flugzeug war wo kein Triebwerk
oder fehlte ein Triebwerk und also es machte so den Eindruck,
als ob diese beiden A50 nicht zur aktiven Flotte gehören.
Das kann natürlich gut sein, wenn sie nicht so viele davon haben,
dann dürften die, die noch da sind unter Umständen auch einfach in der Luft
sein die ganze Zeit, so gut das eben geht.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist das aber trotzdem ein Schlag, weil natürlich die nicht
mehr gebaut wird und die anderen, die nicht mehr in Betrieb sind,
natürlich immer noch Ersatzteile liefern.
Und wenn sie da auf jeden Fall schon mal die Radare zerstören,
damit verhindern sie auf jeden Fall, dass man mit denen noch irgendwas Sinnvolles anfangen kann.
Ja, also das war sozusagen die komplette Flotte, die jetzt angegriffen wurde.
Außerdem gab es noch ein Transportflugzeug, so eine Yushin, irgendwas, die noch...
Nee, Antonovs, zwei Antonovs. Nee, eine Antonov.
Genau, Ilyushin 21 oder sowas. IL-21 war das.
Weiß ich nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall, das kam noch unter die Räder und dann
haben sie irgendwie noch ein paar Tanklager auch noch angegriffen.
Was bei dem Angriff noch gemutmaßt wurde, das ist so ein bisschen unconfirmed,
aber ist auf jeden Fall nochmal interessant das zu reflektieren.
Es hieß halt am Anfang, diese Drohnen hätten eine AI-basierte Zielsteuerung gehabt.
Und andererseits hat man jetzt gesehen, wie die eben mit Live-Video,
mit dem FPV-Modus gesteuert wurden.
Und ich glaube, der Konsens ist so ein bisschen, es gab beides.
Also die haben tatsächlich von all diesen Flugzeugmodellen auch noch in der
Ukraine in ihrem Flugzeugmuseum welche rumstehen und haben wohl mit Bildern
davon ein entsprechendes Model trainiert,
sodass diese Drohnen im Zweifelsfall in der Lage gewesen wären,
wenn sie nicht mehr ferngesteuert sind,
dass sie trotzdem rumfliegen, nach so einem Flugzeug suchen und die entsprechende
Stelle ansteuern, um dort dann zu explodieren.
Das wäre wohl möglich gewesen und man weiß nicht, ob es auch irgendwie zum Einsatz
kam oder ob die Drohne es versucht hat und es nicht funktioniert hat.
Also das wird uns natürlich die Ukraine jetzt nicht erzählen.
Aber das scheint so ein bisschen Thema gewesen zu sein.
Und andererseits, wie schon berichtet, jede Drohne hat einen eigenen Operator
und das hat wohl auch ganz gut funktioniert, sodass ich jetzt überhaupt nicht
weiß, inwiefern das zum Einsatz kam.
Aber das ist definitiv so ein Thema. Der Schaden, den die Russen jetzt davonziehen,
der lässt sich auch schwer beziffern.
Ich habe von zwei bis sieben Milliarden US-Dollar alles gehört.
Das ist natürlich ein hypothetischer Preis, weil erstmal kostet das in Russland
nicht US-Dollar, sondern Rubel.
Zweitens sind das ja Flugzeuge, die gar nicht mehr gebaut werden,
das heißt man kann die jetzt nicht kaufen also es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass wenn sie jetzt 7 Milliarden in die Hand nehmen, dann hätten sie morgen wieder neue,
sondern das ist einfach diese existieren einfach nicht mehr ich glaube nur für
diese TU 160 existiert noch eine Produktionsstraße.
Nee, es ist keine Produktionsstraße, sondern Handfertigung.
Also die Möglichkeit, die zu bauen, sagen wir es mal so.
Ja, aber sozusagen es gab mal Produktionsstraßen, die haben halt die Dinger
in Serie rausgehauen und jetzt sagen, schaffen sie ungefähr eine davon pro Jahr zusammenzubauen.
Eine, okay.
Eine pro Jahr ungefähr. So, deswegen keine Produktionsstraße,
weil wenn du nur eine pro Jahr baust.
Ich nehme das Wort Straße zurück und sage, die T160 können Sie überhaupt noch
produzieren, dafür haben Sie die Teile, die Technik, die Leute,
das ist sozusagen möglich, die zu bauen.
Die ein, weil da habe ich zufällig auch, jetzt gehört das Problem ist,
die, die sie bisher produziert haben,
haben sie noch mit Altteilen quasi, die vorproduziert waren,
zum großen Teil zusammengesetzt oder halbfertig.
Also viele davon waren eben unfertige Maschinen, die mal noch zu Sowjetzeiten
angefangen wurden zu bauen und nicht fertig gemacht wurden. Die haben sie fertig gebaut.
Das heißt, man geht davon aus, dass sie eben dann viele Teile einfach in Handfertigung
so Einzelstücke irgendwie anfertigen müssen und das teilweise oder Ersatz brauchen.
Also eine pro Jahr, das sagt, glaube ich, schon so ein bisschen was über die
Produktionsfähigkeiten aus. Heißt natürlich nicht, dass sie nicht vielleicht
dann doch eine Produktionsstraße aufbauen könnten dafür.
Aber bei dem Tempo jedenfalls im Moment, ja,
vor allen Dingen rechnet man auch noch ein, dass natürlich die Triebwerke und
auch die Airframes haben eben.
Das ist nur eine begrenzte Haltbarkeit. Das heißt, wenn die im Einsatz sind
und gerade wenn die täglich fliegen, irgendwann nutzen die sich auch ab.
Das heißt, der Grad der Abnutzung ist wahrscheinlich höher als das,
was abgeschossen wird durch den Krieg.
Also zweifelsohne ist das ein ganz schwerer Schlag gewesen, also je nachdem
welchen Zahlen und Einschätzungen man jetzt glauben will,
aber man kann locker sagen, die Russen haben mindestens 10,
wenn nicht 20 Prozent ihrer strategischen Luftflotte einfach in einem Tag verloren.
Und das, abgesehen davon, dass der Wert davon nicht zu beziffern ist,
haben sie realistisch keine Möglichkeit, die auch nur in irgendeiner nennenswerten
Zeit ersetzt zu bekommen durch irgendetwas anderes,
weil sie auch gar keine Nachfolgemodelle haben, die sie jetzt bauen könnten.
Und selbst wenn sie das jetzt starten, das kann dauern und das ist halt dann auch richtig teuer.
Das Ganze war von der Idee her, von der Logistik her, von der Technologie,
die hier entwickelt und zum Einsatz gebracht wurde, einfach eine absolute Meisterleistung.
Und vor allem ist es für die Russen nicht nur ein großer Schaden,
sondern erzeugt jetzt auch noch diverse Dilemmata.
Jetzt haben sie erstmal angefangen alle Trucks zu kontrollieren rund um diese
Airbases, weil sie natürlich davon ausgehen mussten, dass jetzt in irgendeinem
anderen Truck wieder irgendwelche Drohnen aufsteigen und dass ihnen dann morgen
irgendwie auch noch der Rest ihrer Flotte weggehauen wird.
Das hat wohl nicht stattgefunden ich habe auch nicht gehört,
dass irgendwas gefunden wurde oder so,
ich denke mal dieses Angriffsszenario ist jetzt auch erstmal verbrannt,
ein guter Grund warum die Ukraine das sozusagen an fünf Standorten wirklich
zeitgleich gemacht hat damit sie einfach,
sozusagen dass die Methode danach unter Umständen nicht mehr funktioniert das
wussten die dann irgendwie auch das erzeugt natürlich jetzt lange Staus und
hält den ganzen Truckverkehr in Russland auf.
Also wir werden jetzt nicht jeden Truck überall in ganz Russland kontrolliert
haben, aber zumindest jetzt um militärische Bereiche herum.
Und ja, das ist natürlich auch schon mal ein Riesenschaden und verunsichert
alle und kratzt vor allem an diesem Nimbus der Unverletzlichkeit.
Und das bedeutet auch, dass die Angriffe auf die Ukraine jetzt schwieriger werden,
weil sie auf andere Flugzeuge ausweichen müssen oder einfach nicht genug haben.
Es war definitiv ein riesiger Verlust, was man auch daran merken konnte,
wie die russischen Medien darauf reagiert haben, wie Putin darauf reagiert hat,
dass sie nämlich versucht haben, das mehr oder weniger zu ignorieren und runterzuspielen.
Das ist dann, wenn dann das als Meldung unter ferner liefen,
kommt so an Stelle 5 in der öffentlichen Nachrichtensendung,
ja und im Übrigen wurden irgendwie ein paar Flugzeuge beschädigt.
Aber bei einem Angriff der Ukrainer, aber wir werden die alle reparieren.
Das war quasi die offizielle russische Haltung.
Gleichzeitig wurde dann aber durchblicken lassen,
dass das irgendwie eine ungeheure Provokation gewesen ist und dass man jetzt
mit Atomwaffen zurückschlagen müsste,
weil jetzt die nukleare Triade und Abschreckung gefährdet ist.
Und so, ja,
also diese zwei Arten von Propaganda standen sich dann entgegen,
wobei erst das Runterspielen war dann Putins offizielle Haltung,
aber dann in den sozialen Netzwerken, vor allen Dingen natürlich auf Telegramm,
ging es halt ganz anders ab.
Weil die Bilder natürlich sind einfach super spektakulär.
Insofern ist das Ganze auch noch nicht nur, wenn das Ganze jetzt stattgefunden
hätte und es hätte keine Bilder gegeben, wäre das immer noch ein riesiger Sieg gewesen.
Aber mit diesen Bildern, wo du ja teilweise siehst, auch wie die.
Von einer Drohne aus, die eine andere Drohne dann tatsächlich in das Flugzeug
einschlägt, weil normalerweise Drohnen, also FPV-Drohnen haben das Problem,
dass sie sich selbst nicht beim Explodieren filmen können.
Das ist ein Propagandaproblem, ja.
Insofern, ja, besser vielleicht, wenn du mal zwei Drohnen losschickst,
was ja auch gemacht wird, wo du dann gucken kannst, Was ist denn passiert?
Und das hat man hier auch.
Also kann gar nicht überbewerten, den Propagandagewinn und natürlich auch,
was das so mit der russischen Moral macht, mit den Soldaten,
die davon betroffen sind.
Das stärkt natürlich nicht gerade die Moral und auch die Elite oder Großteil
der Bevölkerung, die sich interessiert und das gesehen hat.
Diese Bilder sprechen einfach für sich.
Das ist das Ding und hilft sicherlich Putin auch nicht und seinem Beruf und
der Bereitschaft, diesen Krieg weiterzuführen.
Weil was auch klar ist, dass der Krieg enden wird, erst wenn genug Kriegsmüdigkeit
auf russischer Seite da sein wird.
Und da ist man mit dem Angriff sicherlich ein Stückchen weitergekommen.
Insofern super Aktion.
Sonst noch bemerkenswert die ganzen Einblendungen, die du dann in den Filmen siehst.
Teilweise siehst du, dass es
keine GPS-Fix gibt, weil wahrscheinlich dort irgendwie Störsender da sind.
Andere Drohnen siehst du, dass sie wohl GPS haben.
Und dann natürlich, was mir auffällt, ist das Failsafe.
Also es steht halt groß irgendwie Failsafe obendrin.
Das heißt, auf irgendeine Art und Weise sind die wahrscheinlich degraded, die Drohnen.
Also sie befinden sich in einer Art Failsafe-Mode. Aber vielleicht war das nötig,
aus irgendwelchen technischen Gründen, diesen Failsafe-Mode zu aktivieren.
Was soll dir dieser Failsafe-Modus bewirken normalerweise? Was heißt das aus deiner Sicht?
Naja, oft hast du halt, also ich weiß nicht, was dieser Failsafe-Mode spezifisch
macht, aber normalerweise, ich meine,
Failsafe-Mode ist, wenn bestimmte Teile, was weiß ich, wenn du keinen GPS-Fix
hast oder wenn irgendetwas anderes der Fall ist.
Es könnte natürlich auch Fail-Safe-Mode sein in dem Sinne, dass wenn das Ding
abstürzt, es auch explodiert.
Das könnte auch eigentlich Fail-Unsafe, aber es könnte auch bedeuten,
das Ding ist jetzt scharf und wenn das auf dem Boden aufschlägt,
egal ob die Granate jetzt fallen
gelassen wird, sondern dass es möglicherweise irgendetwas aktiv ist,
weil es ist jedenfalls kein normaler Mod.
Nicht das normale Verhalten, sondern es ist irgendwo ein spezieller Modus,
wo bestimmte Funktionalität nicht vorhanden ist.
So würde ich das ausdrücken.
Naja gut, also ich meine, immerhin war sie noch in der Lage,
ein Video zu senden und das abzuspeichern.
Von daher kann der Fail nicht so groß gewesen sein, aber wissen wir jetzt nicht.
Tja, ja, ne, ne.
Also die haben jedenfalls in irgendeinem Degraded Mode, das heißt es kann sein,
kein GPS oder es kann sein irgendwas anderes.
Warum sollten die da überhaupt GPS verwenden? Wenn dann doch Clonass, das russische System.
Ja, wenn, dann ist alles gestört. Also die Störsender stören alles.
Na gut. Also auf jeden Fall, um das abzuschließen, diese Operation war,
hat auch, sagen wir mal, die Ukraine auch wieder auf das diplomatische Parkett gehoben,
weil, ich meine, wir erinnern uns ja noch an diese unsägliche Situation im Opel
Office, wo irgendwie da Vance und Trump irgendwie auf Zelensky angeschrien haben
und Trump so meinte so, ja, you don't have the cards.
Und das war natürlich dann auch so das erste,
was aus allen Kanälen kam sieht so aus als ob er doch noch ein paar Karten im Ärmel hat,
und man darf die Ukraine an der Stelle auch einfach nicht,
unterschätzen, weil es ist einfach das haben wir schon mehrfach hier so betont und ich sag's nochmal,
das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auf eine gewisse Art und Weise derzeit einfach
das mal abgesehen von Israel das intelligenteste und modernste Militär,
was derzeit so auf diesem Planeten weilt.
Und es hat natürlich auch, also der Angriff war so episch, dass er natürlich
auch zu einer Memflut geführt hat.
So sehr schön fand ich einfach den ja,
Ukraine has no cards und Putin has no planes. so.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch gleich mal zu dem nächsten Schlag, weil ein paar Tage
später, als sich alle noch irgendwie den Kopf schüttelten von dieser Spiderweb-Aktion,
gab es dann die nächste Nummer,
die offensichtlich auch mit Drohnen ausgeführt wurde.
Es gab eine große Explosion an der Kerchbrücke, also die Brücke,
die Russland mit Krim verbindet,
ein Symbol auch der russischen Herrschaft über ukrainische Gebiete,
in dem Fall halt die Krim und schnell gebaut, nachdem die Krim besetzt wurde
und die natürlich dann auch lange Zeit diese Truppenaufstockung auf der Krim
unterstützt hat, in gewisser Hinsicht immer noch tut.
Es gab zwei halbwegs erfolgreiche Angriffe der Ukraine auf diese Brücke.
Wir erinnern uns an die Explosion des Trucks.
Da hatten sie halt die explosiven Materialien auf dem Truck und haben den dann halt gezündet.
Und der zweite Angriff war...
Eine Explosion unter der Brücke von einer Wasserdrohne,
die dann nach oben den Zusammensturz der Straßenseite zur Folge hatte,
also so zwei, drei Teile dabei eingebrochen.
Das wurde alles mittlerweile repariert von der Tragexplosion.
Ist immer noch so ein bisschen unklar. Ich meine bis heute sind schwere Züge
immer noch nicht dort unterwegs.
Also es hat sozusagen schon nachhaltigen strukturellen Schaden angerichtet.
Aber insgesamt steht die Brücke halt noch.
Und jetzt gab es die dritte Explosion. Und die dritte Explosion fand statt am
Sockel der Brücke und zwar an der Stelle, wo die Schiffe unter dieser Brücke durchfahren.
Weil die Brücke sperrt ja jetzt im Prinzip das Asowsche Meer vom Schwarzen Meer
ab und Schiffe haben überhaupt keine Möglichkeit an dieser Brücke vorbeizukommen,
weil die relativ niedrig gebaut ist,
bis an einer Stelle, wo es halt einen Überhang gibt.
Der ist so 227 Meter breit und dort geht der ganze Schiffsverkehr durch.
Und die Kerzbrücke ist ja auch rein technisch, sind es ja zwei Brücken.
Es gibt die Straßenbrücke und es gibt die Eisenbahnbrücke. Die Eisenbahnbrücke
ist die auf der nördlichen Seite, also zum Asowschen Meer hin,
entsprechend Straßenseite zum Schwarzen Meer hin.
Und die Explosion fand halt an einem der beiden Sockel bei dieser Durchfahrt
der Eisenbahnbrücke statt.
Also auf der Straßenbrücke, dachte ich.
Da das sozusagen auf dem Video nicht so ohne weiteres zu erkennen war,
weil du sahst nur so diesen Sockel und diese Absicherungsflöcke,
die da sind, die sind sozusagen auf beiden Seiten,
dachten alle, das müsste ja von der Schwarzmeerseite her gekommen sein.
Aber dieser Angriff galt dem Sockel auf der Eisenbahnbrückenseite und dort kam
es unter Wasser zu einer Explosion.
Die Ukraine hat jetzt gesagt, okay, das waren wir und sie haben aber nicht gesagt, wie.
Und darüber gibt es auch noch so diverse Spekulationen. Aber was gemeinhin eigentlich
vermutet wird, ist, dass es sich um eine Unterwasserdrohne handelt.
Also dass sie da wirklich mit Tauchern unter der Brücke waren und Sprengstoff
angebracht haben, ich glaube, das ist einfach unrealistisch.
Wie sollen die da hingekommen sein?
Das ist ja alles weitgehend überwacht und abgesperrt Und Taucher würden da einfach auch auffallen.
Und sie haben halt mittlerweile so Torpedo-ähnliche Drohnen,
die tausend Kilometer weit fahren können und die angeblich jetzt hier 1,1 Tonnen
Springstoff zur Explosion gebracht haben.
Das ist auch eine massive Explosion gewesen.
Da die auch unter Wasser stattgefunden hat, dürfte die auch ordentlichen Schaden angerichtet haben.
Ich habe mir so ein Video angeschaut von so einem Brückenexperten,
der das mal so ein bisschen analysiert hat und der auch mal so erläutert hat,
wie denn eigentlich diese Brücke dort gebaut ist.
Das ist so, dass das Meer dort nicht sonderlich tief ist.
Trotzdem ist aber der Boden relativ weich und damit da die Brücke zuverlässig Halt findet,
haben die Russen dort so eine ganze Reihe von 72 Meter tief in den Boden reingehenden
Stahlrohren, die mit Beton gefüllt sind,
die sich so diagonal ausbreiten.
Also die dann sozusagen so in die Breite gehen und damit diese Standsicherheit machen.
Wie so eine Wurzel. Genau, wie so eine Wurzel. So 110 Stück sind das glaube ich.
Und in dem Bereich, dort ist vermutlich diese Explosion, dort hat die angesetzt.
Und er meinte, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es hier keinen strukturellen Schaden
gegeben hat, die ist relativ gering.
Also das ist einfach so eine kräftige Explosion, das wird dort schon irgendetwas zerstört haben.
Das hat jetzt nicht zum Einsturz der Brücke geführt, aber er verglich das auch
so ein bisschen mit dem Fall, wenn dir irgendwie ein Bein weggetreten wird,
dann stehst du halt noch auf dem anderen, aber du stehst da halt nicht besonders sicher sozusagen.
Also sollte es nochmal einen Folgeangriff geben auf dieselbe Struktur,
dann könnte das gleich schon ganz anders aussehen.
Die Brücke war auch eine Weile gesperrt, aber wurde dann wieder freigegeben.
Wie auch immer die Russen da ihr Assessment betrieben haben,
dass sie in der Kürze der Zeit da schon belastbare Ergebnisse hatten,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Aber ich denke mal, was Transporte über die Brücke mit schweren Zügen betrifft,
das werden sie sich schon nochmal überlegen.
Ja, und das ist etwa das, was man darüber weiß.
Hat stattgefunden, könnte sich wiederholen. Und zum zweiten Mal binnen einer
Woche hat die Ukraine geschafft, mit Drohnentechnologie, über die kein anderes
Land verfügt, hier ihrem Gegner einen schweren Schlag zu verabreichen.
Ja, also meine Vermutung wäre oder...
Wie ich das versuchen würde zumindest. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist das natürlich
relativ naheliegend, sodass die Russen eigentlich dagegen eine Gegenmaßnahme haben müssten.
Aber da ist ja eine ganze Menge Schiffsverkehr.
Das heißt, ich würde mich im Zweifelsfall einfach an irgendein Schiff, was da durchfährt,
als Drohne jetzt, das ich mit Magneten oder sonst wie, die unten dann fest krallen
an dem Schiff und dann, wenn das Schiff die Brücke passiert,
zu Boden fallen lassen.
So, dass wir halt irgendwie...
Den Schiffsverkehr zu blockieren, meinst du jetzt?
Nee, einfach eins der Frachtschiffe, was da durchfährt, also sich mit einer
Drohne quasi da drunter zu kleben, da reinzukommen, um durch die russischen Barrieren da zu kommen.
Ja gut, die Barrieren sind ja auch nicht vollständig, also das ist ja nicht
so, das ist ja kein Staudamm, den sie da errichtet haben, es gibt ja immer Löcher
und eine Drohne kann natürlich da auch den Weg um diese Barrieren herum finden.
Ja, oder wie gesagt, unter einem Schiff, was dort fährt oder im Lärmschatten,
Weil wir werden dort wahrscheinlich Mikrofone haben, die Russen,
wo sie halt versuchen, dann die Drohnen auch anhand von Geräuschen zu orten und so.
Und ja, eventuell auch entsprechend Sonar benutzen.
Und das kannst du wahrscheinlich am ehesten damit austricksen,
indem du dich einfach unter ein anderes Schiff drunter kreilst oder unter einem
anderen Schiff bewegst.
Da gibt es ja auch ganz viele Romane, wo U-Boote sich unter anderen Schiffen verstecken.
Ja, also es ist sicherlich noch genug Kreativität möglich, also was da noch alles kommen kann.
Ich schätze mal, wir haben da noch nicht alles gesehen, was die Ukraine sich
noch so einfallen lassen wird und das wird noch spannend zu sehen, was da bei rauskommt.
Gut.
So eine Militäroperation wollte ich noch erwähnen, die können wir noch mit reinwerfen.
Es gab ja noch den Abschuss einer SU-35 in dieser Woche, das hat sozusagen dem
Ganzen nochmal die Krone aufgesetzt, durch eine F-16 der Ukraine.
Das ist insofern bemerkenswert, als dass das überhaupt der erste Air-to-Air-Fight
ist, von dem man gehört hat, wo also quasi ein Kampfflugzeug des einen Landes
des anderen Landes abgeschossen hat.
Das ist ja so etwas, wofür diese Kampfflugzeuge auch eigentlich gebaut waren,
aber was in diesem ganzen Krieg so noch überhaupt nicht stattgefunden hat.
Naja, in den ersten Tagen gab es glaube ich auch Luftgefechte,
so als denke ich. Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, das will ich jetzt nicht ausschließen. Definitiv war es aber der erste
Fall, wo eine F-16 zum Einsatz kam.
Und das, obwohl der SU-35 eigentlich nachgesagt wird, dass sie besser ausgestattet
sei, als die F-16, die die Ukraine bekommen hat.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, also was so Radarreichweite und so weiter betrifft.
Trotz alledem scheint es wohl gelungen zu sein und wie wohl derzeit kolportiert wird,
kam dort auch diese von Schweden gelieferte Saab 340, also dieses Überwachungsflugzeug,
das hatten wir glaube ich das letzte Mal schon erwähnt,
kam dort zum Einsatz.
Also mit anderen Worten, das war dann so ein koordiniertes System,
wo also der Jet aus 200-300 Kilometern
Abstand geortet wurde und dann die Koordinaten an die F-16 gegeben hat.
Also nicht die F-16 selber hat die sozusagen detektiert, sondern das Überwachungsflugzeug
hat die detektiert und dann die entsprechenden Koordinaten der F-16 vermittelt,
die dann mit einer R2R-Missile gesagt hat,
okay, dann schießen wir da mal hin, mal gucken, ob wir treffen.
Und dann kam das Ding auch runter.
Insofern auch ein Erfolg, der zeigt, dass diese technische Aufrüstung der Ukraine
an der Stelle reale Folgen hat und insofern ganz gut, dass das auch noch passiert ist.
Von wem ist jetzt diese Info, dass das so gelaufen ist?
Was ist da die Quelle?
Abgesehen davon, dass das auch der vorhin schon erwähnte Jaro nochmal in unseren
Kommentaren gepostet hat, hatte ich das auch noch auf einer anderen Quelle gelesen,
kann ich dir aber gerade nicht benennen.
Ja, ich hatte es auch gehört und es scheint auch plausibel zu sein.
Mich interessierte nur, ob die Ukraine das jetzt eingeräumt hat.
Aber wenn dem so gewesen ist, ist das halt schon sehr bedeutungsvoll,
weil das zum einen dazu führen dürfte, dass dann Russland wiederum den Einsatz dieser Maschinen,
überdenken muss. Ich meine, das sind die teuersten und besten Flugzeuge,
die dort im Einsatz sind, auf russischer Seite.
Und ja, eigentlich ja fünfte Generation sind oder sich in Anspruch nehmen.
Und eigentlich der F-16 bei weitem unterlegen, aber,
auf der anderen Seite, wenn das so gelaufen ist, dann,
dürfte die SU-35 wahrscheinlich gar nicht gemerkt haben, dass da irgendwas auf
sie zukommt, bis es zu spät war.
Weil die F-16 hat dann ja gar nicht ihr eigenes Radar benutzt,
so und das dürfte aus einer Entfernung auch gewesen sein, wahrscheinlich wo auch das Radar der SU-35,
so nichts davon gemerkt hat und man weiß jetzt nicht, mit was für einer Rakete,
das jetzt war, aber die dürfte ihr eigenes Radar wahrscheinlich dann nur im
Endanflug ein paar Sekunden vorher aktiviert haben.
Also ich habe jetzt einige Quellen gefunden, Bild hat es berichtet,
United 24, also eine AIM-120 Rakete kam ja wohl zum Einsatz und dass das irgendwie
mit der Saab 340 detektiert wurde, scheint wohl so zu sein.
Ja, also.
Genau. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen der erste Erfolg einer F-16.
Oder überhaupt das erste Mal, nicht nur in diesem Krieg, sondern das erste Mal,
dass überhaupt eine F-16 ein russisches Flugzeug runtergeholt hat. Ja.
Also kann auf jeden Fall nur positiv sein, erstmal dahingehend,
dass Russland eben jetzt vorsichtiger sein muss und mehr Abstand halten,
was dann hoffentlich zu weniger Bombardements der Ukraine führt.
Und dann hätten wir eigentlich nur noch mal, könnten wir noch mal einen Blick
auf unseren Bundeskanzler werfen.
Der ist ja jetzt angetreten und macht seine ersten Reisen.
Die Reise in die Ukraine haben wir schon erwähnt. Fand ich auch gut,
dass das so eine seiner ersten Maßnahmen war.
Und Besuch in Polen und so weiter. Also das waren alles, Entschuldigung, war in Polen?
Oder war der erste, der erste war glaube ich sogar in der Ukraine,
ich weiß es jetzt nicht. Auf jeden Fall war sein erstes, nee ich glaube das
erste Ziel dürfte wahrscheinlich Frankreich gewesen sein.
Anyway, ich habe verfolgt das nicht so genau, was ich näher verfolgt habe,
war sein Auftritt in den USA.
Du hast den sicherlich auch verfolgt.
Ja, also und ich muss sagen, ich fand das jetzt okay.
Man ist natürlich jetzt immer die Frage, gerade mit Trump, weil man will ja
auch nicht unnötig provozieren, aber man will jetzt auch nicht als Vollidiot
dastehen oder einfach die Klappe halten und.
Ich meine, erst mal war das Ganze aber zeitgleich an dem Tag,
wo sich der Trump-Elon-Musk-Fallout oder wo das Ganze neu eskaliert ist.
So, weshalb viele Fragen im Anschluss dann der Presse in diese Richtung gingen.
Insofern wurde das Ganze jetzt vor allem in den USA überschattet von diesem
Musk-Trump-Konflikt. Das kann man, glaube ich, erstmal festhalten.
Aber Trump hat sich mal wieder zum
Obst gemacht und unser Kanzler hat sich eigentlich ganz okay geschlagen,
beziehungsweise musste Trump halt erklären,
also willst du es erzählen, was passiert ist?
Er hat darauf hingewiesen, es war ja sozusagen im Vorabend des 9.
Junis, also des Tages, an dem einst die Amerikaner zusammen mit den anderen
alliierten Kräften in den Krieg eingetreten sind und dort halt in der Normandie
von England nach Frankreich übergesetzt sind.
Und dann am Ende halt einfach Deutschland von den Nazis befreit haben.
Und Trump meinte halt nur so, ja, das war aber nicht so toll für euch.
Es muss ja ein schlimmer Tag für Deutschland gewesen sein.
Merz dann aber ganz konform mit der Weizsäcker-Doktrin halt so,
ja nee, das hat ja zur Befreiung unseres Landes geführt, um dann einfach auch
nochmal den Punkt zu machen.
Natürlich so ein Fakt, den Trump wahrscheinlich weder kennt,
noch in irgendeiner Form nennenswert findet.
Aber das war natürlich dann schon die richtige Antwort. Und überhaupt hat er
alles richtig gemacht, indem er einfach da nicht angefangen hat,
irgendwie groß auf Trump einzureden, sondern er hat ihn einfach da rumlabern lassen.
Er hat natürlich wieder viel Unsinn von sich gegeben und dann auch noch relativ
klug, wie ich finde, so ein Gastgeschenk mitgebracht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du es gesehen hast, er hat ihm ja eine Geburtsurkunde von
dem Großvater, der ja in Deutschland geboren wurde, von Trump irgendwie gebracht.
Ob ihm das was bedeutet, weiß ich nicht. Aber natürlich gut den Bezug zu Deutschland
hergestellt, so hier guck mal Deutschland,
das liegt doch irgendwie auch sozusagen in deiner Geschichte und Geschenk ist
immer gut und es geht ja um Trump, also Hauptsache es geht ja um ihn.
Also das war schon ein kluger Move, wie ich fand, nicht weltbewegend,
aber auf jeden Fall kein Fehler und die Antwort war korrekt und auch in den
anschließenden Interviews auf Fox News und so weiter,
die Merz da gehalten hat, von denen natürlich jetzt Amerika in der Regel keine große Kenntnis nimmt,
aber was halt stattfand, so hat das dann auch Tullis vermieden,
sich zu dem Konflikt zwischen Trump und Musk zu erinnern. äußern.
Insofern, würde ich sagen, erstmal alles ganz gut gelaufen.
Also ja, und in den USA ist es halt auch einigen Beobachtern nicht entgangen,
dass Merz dann Trump erklären musste,
dass das Ende der Nazi-Herrschaft in Deutschland heute als etwas Positives gilt.
Und dass Deutschland verloren hat und die Nazis nicht mehr an der Macht sind, dass das gut ist.
Ja, aber Trump...
Ein Bild dafür ist, dass wenn irgendwie die USA halt wollen,
dass sie halt durchaus da eine positive Kraft sein kann und genau das jetzt
quasi mit der Ukraine ja auch schon.
Ja, wobei das zu sagen, ob Trump das verstanden hat, Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher,
dass das sozusagen in dem Sinne Merz halt auch indirekt Putin,
Russland mit der Nazi-Herrschaft assoziiert hat.
Ob das in Trumps Kopf reingegangen ist, das wage ich zumindest zu bezweifeln.
Es muss auch nicht in Trams Kopf reingehen, weil am Ende muss es sozusagen seine
unmittelbare Beraterriege, also die Leute, denen er dann immer glaubt,
weil es geht ja immer so rum mit, der Letzte, der ihm was erzählt hat,
das ist dann sozusagen gerade so die aktuelle Wahrheit.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall, ja, muss ich sagen, fand ich jetzt nichts davon peinlich.
Das ist schon mal eine Menge wert.
Das ist schon mal viel wert, denke ich.
Dass Merz auch ein ganz gutes Englisch spricht, hilft sicherlich auch an der Stelle.
Und ja, insofern,
war okay, denke ich.
Genau. Gut, Pavel, ich glaube, damit haben wir es. Das ist die Sendung.
Ja, es ist sagen, ja, Frieden ist weiterhin nicht in Sicht und ja,
Trump enttäuscht weiter, kann irgendwie nur hoffen,
dass er jetzt endgültig eingehegt wird,
aber noch scheint das nicht der Fall zu sein und obwohl er von Putin an der
Nase durch den Ring geführt wird,
scheint er das selber nicht zu kapieren,
was da gerade losgeht.
Was los ist. Und insofern, ja, ich hoffe, das ändert sich.
Aber im Moment sieht es nicht danach aus. Sieht es nicht danach aus.
Und vielleicht noch eine letzte Information.
Trump blockiert auch noch weiterhin den Verkauf von Patriot-Systemen an die Ukraine.
Was halt auch nicht gut ist.
Der Typ muss auf jeden Fall weg. Na gut, das war's.
Wir kommen bald wieder, dann mit unserer USA-Folge hoffe ich und wir halten
natürlich weiterhin Ausschau und Berichten.
Wir freuen uns über eure Kommentare. Fragt auch gerne noch oder sagt gerne noch
Themen an oder habt, wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, was wir vielleicht nochmal ansprechen
können im Kontext des Konflikts, dann machen wir das gerne.
Ja, aber jetzt ist erstmal die Liste leer. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir
hören uns bald wieder. Bis bald.
Jo, macht's gut.